yeah go ahead i just wanted to get clean
audio on you saying no boners in sight
that was all i wanted
how could loki affect phase four
how could it not affect phase four brian
that's mine i don't know
i'm uh i'm excited to find out um it
seems clear that right now marvel's
really leaning into the whole multiverse
thing so that's gonna be
fascinating to watch and see how long
audiences want to keep watching that
happen
over and over again i don't know things
have gotten interesting to find out
extremely weird in a very short span of
time
where yeah yeah just where the
introduction of of the multiverse and
loki was just kind of like okay this is
happening now and everyone
seems to be on board everyone's just
like okay multiverse alligator got it
yes next and it's pretty interesting
and it'll be interesting to see how long
they are able to maintain that interest
and in
and wasn't it a crocodile crocodile was
it out
like nina it was um it was some kind
i thought people were calling him croaky
like crocodile loki
i mean they were that doesn't
necessarily mean that's true it's not
like there's a lot of zoologists in the
mcu probably
don't turtles technically have fins and
tortoises i don't know
i don't know anything about anything in
the animal kingdom
just before the turtle gang goes crazy
in the comments section let me tell you
the turtles yeah be careful
it's we've been doing this for literally
two minutes and we're already
extremely off topic sorry about turtles
just like every other episode
[Laughter]
how do we think how do we think it's
going to affect the mcu specifically tom
uh so i'm uh like i said i'm i'm
interested to see how long we want to
put up with it
how long it's going to stay enjoyable
before people get bored with it because
it sounds like there are
what we have we have at least three
projects coming up uh that are
based pretty firmly in the multiverse
from what anybody can tell right we have
doctor strange
uh in the multiverse of madness kind of
game away then you've got the new
spider-man movie that i feel like
everybody like tried to keep it very
quiet
and alfred molina showed up oh yeah i'm
doing it i'm i'm back
great to be back in the arms after 20
years good to see you
and then ant-man 3. yeah quantum medium
which we know
kang will be in right right because that
was when they first announced the
amazing jonathan majors who i loved in
the loki finale he was perfect
we'll be playing we'll be a part of the
film right
and that's uh that's the other thing
that i'm i'm really interested to see
what they do with it because kang
uh as a character in the comics never
really did anything for me not my
all-time favorite he
always just seemed too convoluted and uh
stupid to to i said it i don't care
caleb conker was stupid can we i mean
knowing what you know about kang
and we'll try to fill in the blanks for
each other what what can you tell us
about the origins of king the conqueror
as a character
i would be happy to okay we begin our
story in the 31st century a young man
named nathaniel
richards gets bored and decides that he
wants to
uh stop living in a futuristic utopia
and instead
go be a pharaoh for a while so he time
travels
so relatable yeah we've all been there
like
yeah if i hadn't had a lot of us uh
kind of exploring our options yeah so he
does that
uh he gets beat up for a while after
that it gets kind of fun he
he he travels back into the future he
meets a girl
he can't take over the 20th century
because there are too many hulks and
ironmen
he uh he tries to impress a girl by by
beating up the avengers
the girl dies then there are a ton of
different multiversal kangs that they
come at
time travel gangs and all these i was
just never
on board with whatever it is he's like a
confusing
time traveling doctor doom very much
yeah
just minus like a lot of the super
powers right
and the cool name king the conqueror
just not a great name that being said
like
thanos i was never super stoked for him
in the comics either and then they
turned him into this really compelling
character and it kind of looks like
that's
the one with kang and i hope they pull
it off yeah nina you
you mentioned something about how good
you thought jonathan majors was in the
loki family and i i agree do you want to
tell us
what you thought generally about that
performance and what you think it
promises for the future of the mcu well
now that i know
uh you know that that kang you know is
maybe not the
the greatest comic book character
according to one tom
tom a singular tom me too
no but now that i know that you know
he's maybe not the most
attention-grabbing villain i think it's
perfect to cast
a really really compelling actor like
like majors i mean
this is the finale aired what one day
after he got his emmy nomination for
lovecraft country which was cancelled
very weird move but he really lights up
the screen and everything that he does
he's definitely like an actor to watch
and
i mean with the right casting and the
right writing and working with
um you know directors like you know
peyton reed'll be doing the third
ant-man and like all these people who
are who are we know are really
do we know who's directing doctor
strange too it is slipping my mind
that's right so yeah he's got sam
raymond thank you so yeah he's going to
work with sam raimi i have every faith
that
he's going to be he's got a great
creative team behind him and i also
think that majors is going to keep
bringing it in his performance because i
just loved like
the really like who cares attitude he
brought to the
character i love when there's like a
super high stakes situation the person's
like oh
whatever he was having a really good
time he was having a great time he
chewed every piece of scenery into
shreds
i loved it and i just think like that's
the right attitude for a marvel villain
i mean
that's why catherine han was so good
that's why kate blanchette was so good
in thor ragnarok like chew the scenery
and really
give it 150 and you're gonna be a good
marvel villain so i think he's gonna be
great
and just from an acting perspective i
think that it
could be a really cool part to play like
yeah from what they've given us so far
like mm-hmm
there are going to be these infinite
different variations on the characters
so he's going to have a lot of stuff to
do yeah
yeah this really cool showcase
i hope yeah that was what i was gonna
say in terms of like
you're gonna get kang in ant-man and the
wasp quantomania and we're gonna see
one interpretation of this character and
then we're gonna get probably again in
doc
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness or one is first
and then the other comes later i don't
quite remember the order
but we're you know we'll there's a
potential to see this character in
every one of these movies in some form
or another like an end of movie stinger
and he's going to have all these
different you're not going to know which
version you're seeing
you know what i mean right it's so
potentially exciting about it which is
you know will he be four or five
different kings in ant-man i don't know
but
it might be six or seven or eight and
all the other movies too and with an
actor
who you know in this he was very funny
and he's really serious and loved craft
country with somebody who can
who could play both sides of the of the
coin i think that
the rules in very good hands yeah i
think it's going to be really cool and
i'm excited that
i'm excited that they didn't take that
long to give us our new thanos right
like when that was first got teased in
the original marvel movies
the first avengers was when we first saw
him obviously everyone all fans were
like
oh thanos is coming i know thanos i
recognize him
but as tom was saying it's not as though
you know with some exceptions i'm sure
um
most people don't think of thanos and go
oh i really like
how he you know he's most he's just a
big purple guy
likes great big strong purple guy he
likes having a shiny love
yeah he's in love with death that was
his big thing and
he's very into equity but you know that
gets overlooked
yeah anyway what i like about it was you
know they set it up in a way that
left a lot to your imagination and then
once they figured it out they went they
they started going in that direction but
here i feel like they've got it figured
out from the outset so kang is yeah
a particular kind of guy in a particular
kind of way and
even though we're going to see different
versions of him probably in all these
different
movies and shows it's going to be i feel
like they've
they're starting off on really solid
footing that has me really excited
well and to piggyback off of that like
in terms of you know how it's going to
affect phase 4
i think everybody was like what is going
to be the next
crossover thing now that there's not
more avengers that's going to bring
everybody together and create a
multi-movie conflict
uh even with things that you know let's
letting something stand alone because
you know
as we discussed today looking over the
phase four list like
some things you're like kang will be in
that this will have to do with the story
and then other things you're like
probably not that's
not probably not going to be related i
had a thought about that
i have i have a thought about how
they're going to incorporate kang and
the multiverse into all these movies
that wouldn't seemingly have anything to
do with it
like is it photoshop chang well
you're not too far off right you know
how sometimes in a movie
you know you'll be filming one thing and
then there's a guy in the background and
then they cut to someone else and then
they come back and the guy's gone
or there's different people you think
they're just gonna put kang in the
background of
everything well i mean something like
that i think they might start to
introduce some interesting continuity
errors
that are a bit more noticeable
and people will be like oh look at this
mistake look at that mistake and then
event then one in one of these movies
you're gonna have like this flashback
so all the times things were subtly
changing and that's characters hopping
it feels like hopping dimensions hopping
time i mean
i never watched any of these shows
because i enjoy sleeping at night but um
i've written about enough of them to
like haunting of hill house haunting a
fly manner like all the ghost
hunting people did in like the frames
where it was like there was a go
you know a ghost in almost every frame
of the show or something that's all
right and
you know people had to keep finding them
again i would rather pluck my eyes for
my skull than watch that no offense
i'm just i'm such a wimp
[Laughter]
i can't do it i just can't i would never
sleep no one's asking you to it's okay
don't put your eyes out
i work for pop culture website i feel
pressure it's okay it's all right
i think you're under something really
cool there though that like
uh intentional errors will end up
forming the backbone
continuity i hope they do that because
that'll be a fun easter egg
like one scene in no way home right like
ned will be there wearing a hawaiian
shirt that's blue and then they'll get
to peter park and then they'll come back
and he's wearing a hawaiian shirt that's
red and no one will say anything
and we'll all just be like huh what and
it's just it'll be little things and
then as time
goes on this is in my head this is
what's gonna happen i love it so i just
that's that's how i think it could
affect
everything you know you know what i'm
excited about this
so much yeah i i like this idea a lot i
would love it even more if they did
exactly what you're talking about and
they just never paid it off
if they spent like the next two years
sure just com
like getting in the head of every
pedantic nerd that watches
an mcu movie oh you want that i would be
right there with you really
you want to take this concept and just
ralph boner yeah i was just thinking
that
i don't even want them to ralph boner it
like i want it to feel very much like
there might be a payoff and then they
just drop it completely
like there's there's nothing at all it's
just for a couple of years there are
these
giant egregious errors in these movies
but
spider-man's not wearing the same suit
as he was yes
he's played by a different actor maybe
like swap out tom holland for someone
else
i mean that might have i mean that that
looks like it's probably going to happen
in one way or another where we're going
to get
right right yeah no i just mean
like literally in one scene just like
put andrew garfield in and then cut back
and then it's time
to get and never talk about it hire
robert downey jr to be an extra
just in the background yeah of a shot
and just watch the world
set itself on fire pay him like a mil
like five million dollars to be in the
background of an absolute coffee shop
yeah if i had marvel money and i was
making these movies that would be
the first thing i would do are you sure
you want to admit that you would just
troll
marvel fans are you sure that's for you
absolutely absolutely i would i would
troll any fans
i fear for the comment section on this
video before the last harry potter book
came out i thought that they should have
made i thought it would have been great
if uh if
pete's the poultry guys wound up being
like the central character to the whole
thing just to watch like the movies have
to spin their wheels really hard
i think there's a lot to this so i'm
also very
you love chaos tom i'm being arrived on
it
yeah one thing i read today that i
thought was interesting was that kang is
actually the first
character that the mcu has officially
brought in
that was formerly owned by fox that they
couldn't use
oh did you read that on a website called
looper.com brian
uh i'm going to say yes even though the
answer is
technically no um i did read it though i
mean it's interesting i mean it's it's
definitely yeah
it's really interesting so what's what's
cool about it is he was formerly
a fantastic four villain because um well
he's been an avengers villain as well
but his
his identity is nathaniel richards and
there's obviously
in continuity he is known to be a
descendant of reed richard
maybe well potentially right and so he's
definitely
uh uh pestered the fantastic four in the
past
and so what's cool here too is that
obviously we've got this multiverse
opening up it's happened it's happening
and that easily opens up the door for
finally deadpool x-men fantastic four
which we know is coming
so this is like this is really finally
the official start i know we all thought
in wanda vision that once quicksilver
showed up
oh here it is multiverse and then yeah
yeah
bone and no yeah um but here
no boners still not okay with it i think
it see
that's so funny because i thought it was
funny i was like
all the fan theories didn't pay off i
had like a hearty little
witch article
[Applause]
that was your robert downey junior as an
expert yeah yeah yeah i was like
and i just i'm 12 so i was like boner i
just laughed at it i thought it was
funny
and i like evan peter so i don't really
i mean i
would just go back i enjoyed it i hope
they bring them back that's
yeah go ahead i just wanted to get clean
audio on you saying no boners inside
that was all i wanted right
what i was going to say what i was going
to say is that i mean as good as that
joke is
the the downside is that we don't get to
see
ralph right evan peters as takes over
anymore
this franchise started out being about a
guy with metal clothes
and now we've got witch hunt era
sorcerers and
the eternals are about to pop up if
anybody can explain those succinctly
i will happily seed my job to them
yeah yeah i'm just saying like the
door's open yeah
yeah the door is open thanks for
watching
please hit like and subscribe so you
don't miss a single video